if you're feeling kind of frustrated
with the pool renovation
and you're just hanging in there
waiting for that final result
can I just say same
I miss life as I knew it
but I'm pretty sure that this is the final update
before *the* final update
so settle in cause we've got a bit of ground to cover
in previous updates we've dealt with some of
the more aesthetic stuff
like the tiling and the coping
and I can't believe I'm actually saying it
but the end is officially in sight
but first we have to deal with
you know
the actual pool
First order of business
was to hit the surface with a really good
cleaning and prep product
to get rid of any residue
and oh my goodness this process was more satisfying
than my wedding night
so this product is called True Prep and we
purchased it from a brand name Cotec
but can I just say that Grant and his team
have been phenomenal
a few weeks back
they came out and did a site visit and
recommended what products we would need
they even sent across data sheets
and technical specifications and tutorials to watch
which you know
naturally I forwarded to my husband
and after a lot of phone calls and questions
Cotec made us feel really confident that we
knew what we were doing
which is a bloody miracle
we've also had another pool professional
coming out and checking on our progress each week
and I think I did mention that in part 1
but just to reiterate if you're insane like me
and you're thinking of undertaking a
project of this magnitude
please reach out to your local network of experts
side note
but a lot of people have been concerned
that my pools gonna crack
or even pop up out of the ground
and I'm not gonna lie - valid concern
I've been worried about it too
just to put your mind at rest
before we started we did check that we have
a hydrostatic valve
which should hopefully make that not happen
anyway if you remember in the previous update
we were making holes in the bottom of the pool
terrifying I know
and now it's time to fix them
and we're using another product
from Cotec called Tuff Floor
and this is your trigger warning okay
cause apparently it's gotta look worse before it looks better
I always tell myself when I'm doing projects like this
so you gotta break a few eggs to make an omelette right
but yeah
it's gonna look pretty rough after
but we've got to fix that pool cancer
the way I understand it
pool cancer is essentially where the plaster is cracking
and pulling away from the actual concrete shell of the pool
and that can be really problematic obviously
cause you don't want chlorinated pool water
getting down into that concrete shell
or something
And when the holes were filled
our nephew came to lend a hand sanding
cause she's a big job
he must have heard that I'm only inviting helpers to the pool party
but seriously the last six weeks have been so physically demanding
Mark and I are exhausted and we were so grateful for the help
the next step was to mix up a product called Trowel-It
which was actually so fun
the way that I think of this is
it's like putting on a primer underneath your foundation
you know what I mean
so hopefully
it's gonna make my pool’s pores looks smaller
so that her makeup fits nicer and last longer
K so one question I've had a lot is
what are we gonna do with the weird gap underneath the tiles
where our previous tiles went down to
we kinda had two options
we could either hand cut thousands of tiles to fit in the gap
which wasn't really an option if you ask me
or we could fill it with this stuff before sanding and painting
there was a question mark over a third option
of maybe gouging out that gap to make it big enough to fit a full tile
but we're advised that maybe it wasn't the best option
and also I'm running out of fks to give
so I'm just gonna take these easy road
so we're gonna fill that gap
and also cover up all of the worst spots in the pool
which turns out to be most of it
including literally all of the spa
I don't know why
but the spa I was so rough
there were literally gouges taken out of the wall anyway
so when the pool man came back
he told us that we might have gone a bit overboard with that step
but I don't actually mind
cause guess what?
it's the last thing we need to do before we paint
okay I lied
we have to sand everything again
then we paint
and I'm posting in real time
so I'm so sorry but I promise the
next updates gonna be a goodie